là on se bouge nous sommes d'abord aux
cargos pour vous parler des dix ans de
focus jazz c'est un grand réseau qui
gère le jazz en normandie et qui fait la
fin du mois de jazz ici même ce soir au
cargö
on vous en reparle dans quelques
instants je voudrais tout de suite qu'on
parle d'un autre anniversaire
la 15e édition du festival de bande
dessinée aéroville des planches et des
vaches ça mais daniel quatre volets sont
allés rencontrer un des dessinateurs
chez lui en train de dessiner
jérôme et où est du genre boulimique il
a beaucoup publié en littérature
jeunesse
il a fait des monsieur madame créer les
petits filous et les petits citoyens
mais aujourd'hui et au s'attaque à du
lourd une bd hard rock
par le kitsch pratiquement bannie par
groupe
ouais de rock un peu métal ouais on
comprend le nom way et on les suit dans
leurs tournées dans leur vie dans leurs
gags de tous les jours alors oui le
retourner leur ville surtout leur toutes
les choses décevante qui peuvent faire
au quotidien parce que c'est quand même
le principe de ce groupe là c'est que
c'est comme assez déçu mais enfin la cdc
pardon mais en plus décevant
donc c'est la loose de la page 1 à la
page 48 pour l'anecdote c'est un vrai
groupe
il existe vraiment il tourne et ils sont
avant mais je les adore
c'est quoi l'idée quand on fait un
festival de rencontrer des copains
et puis aussi rencontrer les gens qui
ont la gentillesse de vous lire et puis
de voir si ce qui leur a plu et puis pas
plus quand je fais des albums pour les
enfants puisque c'est quand même aussi
une grosse part de mon activité bas ça
ça permet de de voir des vrais enfants
en vrai et de +10 voilà ouais tout à
fait et de se dire on va là j'avais tapé
juste ou la moins déjà et puis puis bon
on dessine pas que pour soi tout seul
dans son bureau en fait comme un
chanteur et sinon tout seul sous la
douche c'est moins rigolo
bon on rappelle le rendez-vous des
planches et des vaches du 2 le 2 et 3
avril pardon à hérouville saint clair à
la forêt il vous y serez je passais y
est
un obus sifflant a traversé le ciel et
le toit le pédiatre joue le square
vendredi à la halle aux grains de bay
avait plus des tâches plus de chambre il
a couru au village les maisons étaient
par terre il a couru droit devant mais
qu'avez vous fait de vos rêves
charlie soucier chantera pour les
enfants de palestine samedi soir au
théâtre des miroirs à la glacerie dans
la manche
quand vous chantiez la liberté et puis
autre anniversaire celui de l' orchestre
national de jazz qui joue ce soir ce
sont ses 30 ans oui tout à fait alors
que leurs cadets national de jazz fête
ses 30 ans cette année
ils sont en tournée dans toute la france
dans toutes les salles de musiques
actuelles de la france et au cargö ce
soir donc ça réunit dix musiciens qui
sont parmi les meilleurs musiciens de la
scène jazz et musiques improvisées en
france et ça change de formule à tafer
le directeur change je crois que c'est
tous les quatre ans donc là cette année
c'est olivier benoit un musicien la
suite depuis depuis longtemps le
répertoire c'est quoi ces discussions
des standards ou s'ils sont improbables
du toussaint sont des créations al
aulaqi qui mêle un peu le rock voilà il
s'était un peu le fil rouge de du
concert de ce soir et de leur tournée
c'est de montrer que le jazz est ouvert
voilà tout c'est esthétique là le rock
l'électro
d'où la présence ici au cargo qui
représente toutes les musiques actuelles
et aussi le jazz évidemment
on
e
on va signale aussi une première partie
importante oui tout à fait c'est le trio
infernal momus alors c'est un trio qui
est issu de coutances c'est un trio qui
est lauréat du dispositif aux personnes
que le réseau focus jazz à a mis en
place donc voilà c'est un trio qui
bénéficient d'un accompagnement
professionnel pour la diffusion là pour
ses nouvelles créations et s'est plaint
d'anniversaire vous l'avez constaté en
cette fin de semaine et notamment ce
soir au cargö avec focus jazz qui fête
ses dix ans bonnet nniversaire et merci
de soutenir ainsi le le jazz depuis un
mois c'était l'événement palace et c'est
la soirée de clôture et oui il en faut
une meilleure venez ce soir gago